all right how's it going everyone doing
well not too enthusiastic okay so yeah
today we're gonna be talking about web
standards this is my first time using a
clicker so bear with me here
the talk is called Hitchhiker's Guide to
web standards and to kick things off I'd
like to introduce myself my name is DOM
fairly no yes I'm named after the
platform that we all know and love I'm a
senior at the University of Cincinnati
in Ohio and previously I've held
internships at Microsoft and Mozilla
working out in Firefox and I'm gonna be
doing a final internship at Google in
Japan actually working on chromium in
the web platform so currently I'm a
chromium committer which is basically
fancy speak for someone who has write
access and you can approve certain stuff
and I'm also what working group
standards editor so if you don't know
what that last one is that's that's
primarily we're gonna be talking about
today I said from that you can follow me
on Twitter and check out my work on
github and feel free to email me anytime
you know during or after the talk Dom a
crummy org there's any questions about
getting involved in the web platform at
web standards and browsers stuff in
general so I want to talk about what
this talk actually is I kind of have
three overarching goals that I wanted to
reach when working on this talk and the
first one is just provide a background
in history and to web standards and some
of the organizations that are
responsible for their governance and
their authorship
this could really be an its own talk but
I know we didn't come here for a history
lesson so I'm just gonna give a brief a
brief history on this to kind of set the
stage next I want to talk about you know
as a web developer how can you actually
make use of a web standard right a lot
of us go to mdn or Google some API and
figure out how it works but I kind of
want to talk about the technical bits of
web standards and show how you can make
use of them and how to read them and how
to navigate that space finally I want to
talk about how you can get involved I
want to share a bit about my own story
of getting involved with web standards
and working on the web platform and
hopefully encourage some of you to do
the same so to kind of set the stage for
the talk I'd like to propose you know
the idea that we need a definition of a
standard now largely this depends on
context if we're going to define you
know a new word and so I'd like to
propose my own definition for the
purposes of this talk it's a little bit
wordy so bear with me a document
specifying observable effects of
technology with multiple independent
implementations
now it's kind of wordy like I said so
let's just focus on some key points
right we care about the observable
effects of technology what are the side
effects of it how if I run something
what does it do how does it look and
feel how can I actually use it and and
does it change depending on you know
where I'm where I'm using it from and
this last part is multiple independent
implementations technology with multiple
independent implementations I think this
is really important and it's it's far
from a new concept in technology you
know we've seen this with like UNIX
operating systems for example I can kind
of make my own version of you know my
own of Linux distribution you can have
your own Linux distribution and and you
get one and you get one and everybody
can have their own you know separate
distribution with sugar on top of it but
what I really care about as a desktop
app developer if I were one is you know
can I write an application that works
once everywhere and no matter what
operating system I'm using for you know
that's in the UNIX family of os is that
it's gonna work uniformly so to kind of
make that environment conducive to that
you know interoperable behavior among
the different operating systems we've
had the set of plastic standards
developed to kind of unify this
observable behavior the same thing goes
for web tech and this is primarily what
I'm going to talk about today those
these are not actually to scale though
but I happen to know for a fact that you
can't go to the store and you buy one
HTTP you know it's a protocol it's just
it's just an idea and it's something
that you can implement to kind of make
it compatible with other versions of
this this protocol and the same
basically goes for JavaScript as well
right we can run JavaScript in a bunch
of different places unlike maybe Python
it's kind of like we have one Python we
get from the Python people and that's
kind of it but with JavaScript I can run
it in chrome I can run it in an edge on
the chakra engine and I can run it a
node in all kinds of different places
and the same goes for kind of the star
of the talk today which is the web
platform API so I've gone through a
career change I'm now no longer a UNIX
app developer but I'm a web developer
and so I need to know that the same
api's that exists in chrome also we're
going to be there in Firefox and more
importantly that they're all going to
work the same and kind of function
uniformly that's really important
probably the biggest thing I learned
when making this slide is though that
keynote is really cool and has a bunch
of different goofy symbols that you can
use so I thought that that little dude
look like a face so I dressed him up
getting some underwear and a hat and
stuff like that so let's talk about
where web api's come from right this is
important we are we are web developers
and we kind of want
know where the stuff comes from and how
we can make more of them I personally
think the logical answer probably is
JavaScript right we use Web API when
we're using JavaScript for example
here's a snapshot of the chrome dev
tools and when I'm you know right I can
write things like a for loop and a while
loop but I can also fetch you know super
prominent websites on the internet like
that one and I can use set timeout and
all kinds of stuff like that so it
stands the reason that this kind of
stuff is part of the language now we
have to talk about what is the language
or what does JavaScript I'm just gonna
fly through this slide because we all
know the big story of Brendan Eich and
he created it in 10 days and whatever
but it's just a general-purpose
programming language that is created for
the purposes of the web I was plopped
into netscape 2.0 and that made it a
really interesting thing it made it a
candidate for Standardization because
there was going to be multiple
independent implementations of it and so
we needed some group that could come by
and pick up the task of standardizing
and Ekman did this they stand for the
European computer Manufacturers
Association and they created ACMA script
and we've had some success with this
with the various engines for example
there's a bunch of different
implementations of the same sort of
technology and you probably have seen
this list or something similar to it
before the standard looks something like
this
it's really big it's really hard to read
but it's on github and it's hosted under
the tc39 s github page tc39 just stands
for technical committee 39 so when we're
writing the standard writing atma script
how does it work right what are we going
to put in the standard we're making a
new language so we have to make them
make it really general so we need a
really strict separation of concerns
between all the contents in the
standards in the standard we just need
to be dealing with the language syntax
in the semantics and then some of the
constructs and the primitives and that's
the true scripting language it should be
able to be plopped into any host
environment but the language itself
shouldn't actually have to know anything
explicit about that environment
now we're really used to using that
language in a web browser so we're used
to web api's and stuff like that but the
language itself doesn't actually know
about those things so web apos are not
part of the ACMA script language or the
jour JavaScript language they're
effectively mix-ins
and they're baked into browsers and
browsers can support basically a version
of echo script as their JavaScript
engine and a bunch of web api is that we
can use that kind of tag along alongside
this version Rackham script that kind of
interplay with it and so we have hakama
right there responsible for and tc39 are
responsible for standardizing ACMA
script and javascript that we all know
and love so who's responsible for
standardizing the web api so we've kind
of heard a little bit about this today
from some of the talks there's two big
groups right now that are responsible
for this primarily you've probably seen
at least one of these logos before we
have the w3c and the what working group
and the what working group denoted by
the question mark on the right is what
I'm gonna be talking about primarily
today this is the organization I told
you all that I was a part of at the
beginning so the what working group
stands it's just an acronym
unfortunately so it stands for a long
string of text that kind of summarizes
what we do it was formed in 2004 after a
w3c workshop basically they decided to
kind of branch off from the w3c and
create their own canonical standards
that specified the web platform so they
have an HTML standard which kind of
defines HTML language and the parser and
the event loop and a lot of the it's
basically the kitchen sink of the web
platform is actually what it calls
itself to and they have you know they
specified the Dom API is the interface
that we use to talk to the web and and
some networking primitives like fetch
and streams and a lot of really cool
things like notifications and primitives
but how are these things actually
written right if we're gonna write a
browser and we want to write ACMA script
you know we start with the JavaScript
engine okay now if we read the ACMA
scripts back there's a lot of stuff in
there but there's also a bunch of
exposed objects that would get for free
and JavaScript we get things like the
array constructor and you know date
objects and week maps and all kinds of
data structures that are natively
exposed through ACMA scripts but we want
our browser to be a little more powerful
you know we want it to have me the Dom
so we give it you know a document object
we can add a couple more paragraphs onto
the end and give it a query selector
method and we've kind of extended our
language a little bit more the documents
getting bigger but it's getting more
powerful so we also would love to to you
know contact the network as well so
we'll give it some networking primitives
things like fetch things like request
and it'd be really cool if we could do
ourselves a good service and debug our
code so we'll maybe give it a console
object as well a bunch of methods on top
of that this is one way to write it just
keep appending text onto the same
to the same massive documents but it's
going to get pretty lengthy and
unmaintainable so the what working group
maintains separate standards for each of
these kind of ideas that have a
separation of concerns and each standard
is responsible for talking about how
they enter leave with the other
specifications and the web as well as
that can script and things like that and
as a result we get web api is alongside
ACMA script and java script now if we
want to read these web api's as web
developers as web developers we want to
make use of them we need to kind of know
the anatomy of a standard we need to
know what is actually in these documents
because it's kind of a mystical thing in
mystical process and and it's actually
really you know not too difficult to get
involved and it's it's all very open and
happening right under right under our
noses so I was thinking about this a lot
for this talk and I kind of came to the
conclusion that there are two big parts
of standards to kind of be aware of the
first is algorithms so I don't know
about you guys I love algorithms spend
many an evening as it were working on
leet code and hacker ranked stuff and I
really like algorithms and data
structures stuff I think that kind of
theory of computation is really really
cool
algorithms are really just a set of
steps to perform a task so let's go
ahead and take a look at an algorithm
inside a web standard right we have the
console standard and there's a bunch of
different methods on there if you
haven't heard of it there's one called
console dot count and here's the
algorithm specified in the standard
there's five steps that run every time
you invoke console dot count there's a
couple that we really care about for the
purposes of this talk though you can see
we're given something called a label and
basically the idea of this algorithm is
if we've seen this label before when
we've called this in this function then
you know increment some number that we
have that we have associated with label
otherwise we can set it to one this is
the algorithm and then eventually we
want to just print it to the screen this
logger thing is just abstract text for
saying hey browser you know show this to
the user in whatever way you see fit
this is nice because I kiss a web
developer I could come in here check out
the algorithm and it answers a couple
questions for me like you know what is
the initial value of the number that is
associated with a label and what happens
every time I call it and what can I
expect and so we can read the algorithm
and kind of understand what's going on
now the second important thing about
specifying and using web api is
understanding the look in the
so I think that's really important
what's it mean for an API to have a look
and feel so I thought of this and I
think it's kind of like you know what's
it mean to to use the API as a developer
what's it called where is it hanging off
of some other object is it just globally
exposed does it take anything these are
you know a bunch of parameters how many
parameters does it return anything this
stuff is really important for us to know
and a lot of us here are used to going
to mdn and then maybe googling this kind
of stuff to find it but I also want to
show that you can just go to the
standard so here's another part of the
console standard - that the what working
group maintains it's a big scary block
of text but let's focus on the bit
that's complementary to what we were
talking about before the count method so
we have this right this kind of can tell
you a little bit about it right okay so
it's called count it exists under the
console namespace so console that count
that kind of make sense how I would use
it it's of type void so I probably
shouldn't expect to get anything from it
just not gonna really return anything
but I might do stuff and it takes in a
single parameter called label it's
optional and its type is Dom string so
we don't know what Dom string is right
now but let's just assume it's just a
regular string that gives us some some
cool information it's pretty expressive
but it's not JavaScript because we care
about types and and it's not C++ because
we see other invalid things going on
around here so what exactly is this
language it's called web IDL in a sense
for web interface definition language
and you'll see it in a lot of
specifications and it kind of forms a
contract for this basically the
signature of web api is that you use and
that contract protects the algorithm
because when I go into the algorithm and
I'm running these steps I want to be
able to know what label is I need to you
know maybe I'm making some assumptions
that it's a string and I'm operating it
on on that accordingly and that's really
important for me to know and so I want
to talk about how web IDL actually works
in practice okay so you're a while ejs
dev you got your Viking hat on and you
really care about types right so you're
gonna call you're gonna mash in your
keyboard and called console count and
you're gonna just give it whatever you
want you can give it a symbol right you
can give it an object seeing it whatever
but the second you do that the web IDL
Sheriff is gonna stick in it's gonna
come in and it's basically gonna be like
hold up hold up hold up hold up you
called console dot count
and you could give it whatever you want
right symbol if you wanted to be so
inclined to do so you give it a number
whatever but I'm gonna make sure that
you know this contract is obeyed I'm
expecting a Dom string and I'm gonna
make sure that whatever you give me can
pass as a Dom string and if it does
that's cool we go to the algorithm
continue with a hopefully successful
call and and keep going but just like a
sheriff can throw someone in jail the
web buddy el sheriff so to speak can
throw a type error resulting you in with
you in code jail it's probably the worst
place to be right you're staring at the
terminal or sorry the dev tools and you
got all this red scary text around you
don't know what's going on so we want to
stay away from that now real sheriffs in
the real world know who to arrest who
not to arrest stuff like that that's
that's really important something part
of their job so they kind of basically
have a rule book of things to follow
here and just like they're the real
sheriffs of a rule book the web IDL
sheriff has a rule book in the form of
the web IDL standard and it basically
defines a lot of the stuff that that
it's supposed to be enforcing so we saw
an example of conversion here's a
snippet from the web IDL standard that
basically is responsible for converting
a Tekamah script value to what is called
a Dom string something that the web IDL
has defined basically the meat of this
algorithm is just to kind of delegate to
step two and call this two string thing
this is an abstract operation defined in
the ACMA script standard so we're just
kind of passing through right to the
ActionScript spec and we could of course
write to string everywhere we needed to
instead of using web IDL but yeah this
is really nice because it's pretty
expressive it tells us tells us how
things should work in a really normative
clear way and if your techs are
algorithms when I get to here I can know
that I'm working on a string and that
things have been accepted and the
sheriff is okay with it so why are we
using this thing called web IDL anyways
right what exactly is it so it's it's
just an abstraction of arachno script
text as you saw all step two was we just
kind of delegate to the echo script
standard it's two string thing it does a
lot of things for us so it helps us
write a lot with just a few words
potentially it takes care of a lot of
like type conversions we saw a really
simple example of a type conversion but
you can imagine perhaps potentially a
much more complicated one and we would
want to repeat all those steps to you
know it's convert things and then kind
of make our assumptions everywhere where
you need it to in the spec so we can use
web
be able to kind of just abstract that
stuff away it also takes care of things
like property initialization for us and
other stuff like that it also helps us
define where our interfaces are exposed
in a really expressive way it like we
like we saw but I think the most
important thing about web IDL personally
is that you don't actually have to use
it it's as line1 suggests just an
abstraction over action scripts over the
ACMA script text and that's really
important because we have some standards
that are written without web IDL and
that's totally valid it just kind of
speaks within the same language of the
echo script a standard space in that
uses the same verbage and the same sort
of stuff but web by DL is just a nice
way to be succinct and kind of foster
interoperability on the platform so you
can always feel free to you know
hopefully that that little foray into
web by DL makes you a little bit more
comfortable reading some of the
standards that they that they come with
in so finally I want to talk about how I
got involved in this and how and how you
can do the same and hopefully motivate
you to do the same as well so who knows
this logo let's it raise show of hands
right hey a lot of people cool so this
is the angular logo this flat designer
believe this is new since angular 2 and
basically a couple years ago I was like
yeah I'm gonna start like giving more
stuff with web applications so I better
learn a big heavy framework that can bog
me down and figure out how to write all
this stuff and so angular 2 at the time
was an alpha there's a basically mess
right things were always moving around
and I would always hear people say yeah
you know angular angular is getting uh
you know a new router or angular is
getting a new object or new this kind of
stuff and it was really easy to track
the progress of this it was happening on
github I knew some of the people working
on it so you could always just kind of
dig around at the same time I heard
another camp of people kind of talking
about JavaScript there they were saying
you know hey javascript is getting you
know async iterators or you know did you
know about custom elements can you
figure out how to use this and I was
like well that's interesting cuz that's
not really angular specific so I was
really interested in digging around
figuring out who's deciding this stuff
because like like how does this work I
want kind of wanna be a part of it seems
pretty cool we're evolving the platform
so eventually it came across this guy's
profile his name is Dominic Nicola and I
just learned recently that he was
actually a speaker at the first Cascadia
j/s in 2012
it's true that we both have the same
name that's pretty cool and so I reached
out to him I was like hey I see you you
know you're working on you know the what
working groups bit standards and all a
lot of stuff like that big contributor
to the tc39 proposals and so I had
reached out I was like hey what do you
do really and how can I do it - it seems
kind of cool are you actually paid to
work on this stuff it's it's pretty cool
and so he was basically like hey you
know we both have the same name we're
both Dom's right and then working on the
platform so I'll let you in on some
secrets and the biggest the biggest
piece of advice here is probably to dig
around on some of the what working group
standards and actually just take a look
at some issues there's a lot of issue
labels that the issues are kind of fixed
- if one of them is good first issue and
basically as the name implies they are
good first issues for people to get
involved in and a lot of them are
low-hanging fruit or some of them are
editorial in nature that you can just
kind of go in and dig around in a web
standard and figure out how to work with
them I want to cut away though from
keynote and probably screw a lot of
things that up in the process but let's
see if I can just show what the what
working groups page looks like hey do we
have it yes okay now if I can figure out
where my mouse is I would also be cool
one second
all right cool so so here's here's the
what working groups github page
basically just to kind of show you you
know it's all open it's all happening
right in front of you and it's a very
welcoming area you're allowed inside
basically this is this was basically
just a list of all the specifications
that we maintains giant list of the HTML
standard the fetch standard and stuff
like that and so we can always just go
to the one of these repositories and see
what's inside right there must be some
sort of source code that the standard is
you know existent and that it's written
in and a lot of times this will take
form in a take in the form of a BS file
so bs does not stand for [ __ ]
we're actually very serious people here
we're working on standards right we're
on the platform so bs since our bike
shed and it's basically this language
that we kind of mix in with with HTML
and pre process before we build a
standard kind of helps us with
cross-linking and some other fancy
things it's pretty easy to get the hang
of we could check out the source
they're all the standards exist at spec
or you know something dot spec org and
basically they look like this they're
the ones with the green logos that the
browser is actually trust and so we go
in yeah we can check out the standard
all kinds of stuff like that and more
importantly if you're looking to get
involved you can go under the issues
section here
and we have a bunch of different labels
that we use that's not where I'd want to
go so yeah if we want to check out these
issues this for example this is the
fetch standard where things like the
fetch your method exist and the request
object and stuff we could go in and try
to find the good first issues you're
like oh yeah this is really cool right I
can I can dig around here and maybe help
out on some issues and so now we're kind
of on to evolving the web platform right
we're working with a standards body to
help fix some of the problems that
they've identified and the platform is
so this kind of this kind of goes back
to interfacing with the community and
the community groups online so I want to
talk a little bit about this when
dealing with the what working group
there's a bunch of different ways to
communicate with us
we're always on get up of course you can
you know chime in on an issue and be
like hey I really want to work on this
this this looks really cool I think it's
interesting
we're always super super happy to
provide mentoring mentorship for people
that are looking to get involved also
we're on the really big bad scary place
that is IRC we're in the free no under
free node on the web working group
channel
I'm always logged in a lot of us a lot
of the others always logged in so always
available to you also help with
questions and stuff like that there's a
lot of information here that have thrown
at you and things like that and at the
very end of the presentation I'll kind
of give you with a well one web page
that you can go to kind of get a lot of
this stuff from but I want to talk about
why to do this anyways right there's a
lot of cool ways to read it to learn
reasons to learn angular until I react
and to work on the web but I think
what's really cool is is you know I know
we're in Seattle and Microsoft land
basically but if you have a problem with
some Windows api's basically you kind of
have to work in Microsoft to get them
fixed or changed or do something like
that but what the web platform all this
stuff is happening right in front of
your face it's all in github it's all
free to participate and you know anybody
anybody can do it and just go on and
start working on stuff and I think
that's really really cool web developers
are in a really unique position of being
able to influence and modify the
platform that we all develop on every
single day and that's really exciting to
me
and one of the reasons that I got
involved so I want to leave you with a
repository that I just kind of started
the other day now is the time to take
pictures of the slides if you're
interested in getting involved there's a
lot of information there's a lot more
information beyond just what I've
covered in this talk
so check out the Cascadia j/s repository
that i maintain on github it's just kind
of got some getting started information
and so the links to other talks that
people have done on similar stuff and
how to get involved in the web community
and modify web standards and stuff like
that finally I want to leave you with
some of the things that I've worked on
to hopefully hopefully provide some
motivation to show that you guys that
you all can do the same recently I've
changed helfet works the fetch API I've
worked on Chrome to basically modify
when we said credential when we send
credentials when we make a request stuff
like that basically did the same for for
module scripts and took part in some of
the standardization work for there so
that required of course talking to a
bunch of the browsers and saying hey you
know we're thinking about making this
change it kind of makes sense what do
you guys think and can I do it
I also standardized and implemented the
referrer policy attribute this is
security even private security privacy
attribute and HTML so I did this on the
script Elementary simply so I like
resource loading and then security
privacy kind of stuff I've also
implemented a bunch of console API eyes
so the console standard I mentioned is a
really really good one to start getting
involved with so I encourage you to
check it out it's what I started with
and I also started working on Chrome
partially as a result of that finally
I've been working on something called
priority hints which is just a new
resource living API that kind of lets
developers tell the browser what
priority they would like to be
associated with a request it's a new
standard and so we're digging through
that I did the implementation work in
Chrome and so we're just kind of doing
some experimentation to see if it's
gonna be able to pull its own weight but
other than that I hope I've left you
with a good taste in your mouth and when
it comes to web standards and I hope
that you all you know feel motivated to
get involved and contribute back to the
platform thanks a lot that's it
[Applause]